mosquito speaks
echo of moscow
alexa benedictof
mr benedictive i can hear some
lively music on your side
alexi just out of respect for the other
colleagues please refrain from making
such
music poses as it were
and kamsa molska pravda
and if you don't mind minister let's
first give the floor to margaritas
yes i support that
well we didn't understand yet that the
interview has already started
unfortunately
minister lavrov i'm in isolation i would
like to shake your hands but i'll do
that you know
virtually can you hear me yes we can see
we can hear you yes i am in isolation
you know the circumstances are
exceptional both in russia and elsewhere
in the world
but the circumstances are exceptional
not just with regard to the pandemic but
also with geopolitics and russia and all
across the world so i'll start with the
question the world is asking and we are
asking ourselves to
so minister lavrov is there going to be
a war
or not
we sent our proposals to them we were
waiting for their response we got their
response but we're not happy with this
response you know quote eric
demonstrandum
and before that we had said that if we
would not like their response we
were reserving the right to take most
drastic measures to protect our
interests and to respond so can you
elaborate on that minister we're not
going to ban mcdonald's i think
so if i can quote my subscribers they
put this question in the following way
when are we gonna hit washington is
there gonna be a war how long are we
going to drag a refugee so is there
going to be
a war if it
it's up to russia there's not going to
be
war we want no wars
but
you know trampling our interests
ignoring our interest is something we
cannot allow either
i cannot say that the talks are over
you know that
americans and nato allies have taken
more than a month to study our
elementary proposals enshrined in the
draft treaties with washington and with
nato and just the year before yesterday
we got their response
and you know
it
obfuscates things as
the west is prone to do but still there
are some responses to our basic
questions which were very important to
us in particular with regard to the
intermediate and shorter range missiles
you know when the americans
sabotage this treaty we
urge them to show some common sense
and our president sent a proposal to the
oecd
in joining everyone to join our
unilateral moratorium
and agree on verification measures back
then this proposal of house was ignored
right now it's included into their
response you know we also
had an idea of trying to withdraw the
military exercises further from the
frontier from the boundary from
you know the the
the border as it were and there were
other
measures for deconfliction
in particular
the safe distance approach and right now
even though they've been ignoring it for
several years right now they
seem to be
willing to talk about that i think it's
at least something
so to speak but the most important thing
for us is to
settle the conceptual foundations of
european security in 2010 in astana and
before that in 1999 and istanbul all
presidents all prime ministers of the
oec countries put their signature
to a package of documents
and these documents contained
interlinked principles of indivisibility
of security the west is
singling out just one slogan out of this
package namely that each and every
country has the right to choose its
allies and military alliances but you
know
and these packages of documents this
right is conditional on another
principle namely not to strengthen
one's security at the expense of others
and their incantations the west says
that nato's policy is sacrosanct and no
one cannot prevent ukraine from joining
nato it's up to
ukraine to decide on that but when
doing that
the west
avoids any references to this second
part of the principle
and when borrel and other counterparts
of our house say that we need to follow
agreed principles in the euro-atlantic
area not a single one of them
ever mentions either the istanbul
declaration nor the
astana declaration they usually
reference the helsinki final act as well
as the paris charter for in europe of
1990 and these two documents do not have
this uh
provision of not strengthening one's
security at the expense of the security
of others whereas in subsequent
documents russia insisted that such an
obligation should be included
and as
i promised tomorrow today i'm sending
official requests to all of my
counterparts i would like to ask them to
provide an official explanation
with regard to how they are going to
implement the commitments their
countries took upon themselves at the
highest level
this is a moment of principled
importance because before
talking about practical issues of
european security first we need to see
how the west you know i wanted to say
how they're going to
wiggle out of this but i do hope that
they are going to give an honest
response and say what they mean
when
they talk about these documents because
so far they're only implementing their
obligations in a very you know lopsided
manner which is entirely advantageous to
them
and they lose sight of the fact that
this freedom of choice of alliances is
conditional on the need not to
strengthen
one security expense of others roman
please
but if they give the answer many experts
anticipate namely the
response we're not going to be happy
do you think
it can lead to
severing of relations because
for quite some time we've heard now that
the americans are willing to slash
sanctions on you on the leadership even
on you what means even on me am i
deserving of sanctions well
i do not think that there has been any
instance in
time in history that sanctions were
contemplated against the president and
against the foreign minister and just
remember the statement of our ambassador
in the u.s
who said that all of this could even
lead to
severing of ties because our diplomats
are basically being expelled even though
it's done under a different source well
there are many layers to your questions
severing of ties
hypothetically is it possible
let me begin with the most important
thing if the west doesn't listen to the
voice of reason what are we going to do
the president has already given an
answer to that if our attempts to agree
on mutually beneficial mutually
acceptable principles of ensuring
security in the euro-atlantic
area
if these attempts fail we are going to
take measures and response with regards
to what kind of measures he said they
can be different it's going to be based
on the information provided by our
military and of course other agencies
and government bodies will participate
in drafting these measures at least at
this point in time at the interagency
level we are studying the
responses from nato and from the u.s the
contents of these documents
are known almost to everyone by this
point in time
i've said that
but i can tell you that the american
response is you know sort of an
exemplary
document of
diplomatic courtesy whereas the native
document is filled with
nato's pride and you know i i felt a
little embarrassed for those who wrote
this document
now
the
possible
measures and response
will be reported to the president they
are going to be drafted but so far we
are going to act
in the manner i've just described now
speaking about sanctions when our
presidents spoke in particular we told
the americans that the package of
sanctions that roman has just mentioned
coupled by
russia's disconnection from the
financial systems well
it would be tantamount to severing of
ties this is something we said to the us
and i guess they understand that and i
don't think it serves anyone's interest
as far as their behavior with regard to
our diplomats is concerned i can tell
you this several years ago
to be more precise in december 2016 when
i last was in washington that was
president trump's uh
last
month in the white house
and i was uh saying goodbye
to
state secretary till no it was not
tillerson it was pompeo
and
he said we are thinking how to optimize
you know the functioning of our
diplomatic missions on a reciprocal
basis and there is something i need to
tell you you know
americans
american diplomats work three years
abroad and then they rotated or
transferred back to washington
and that's why we believe that you need
to do the same your diplomats also need
to stick to this three-year term no more
than three years
our question was
why are you doing that in such a
clandestine manner and are we the only
ones whom you are telling this do we
have similar measures where they got to
other countries the answer was no
there are no other countries
that would participate in this
experiment only russia
and that is when yet another spiral of
our
diplomatic horn locking started
and we said
if we have to stick to this three year
term then you know as our practice goes
you
have do do not have to hire local
citizens to work for the diplomatic
mission they had 400 people working here
and the same goes for you know you know
russian citizens but also people from
central asia and you know when this
discussion
kicked off
and there were shouts and screams you
are disconnecting us from the network as
it were
but we said if you want to follow this
principle you know that you can do
whatever you want and you impose what
you think is right on us then we will
follow in your footsteps
this was yet another bout of crisis that
first flared under obama
he showed his true colors several
weeks or months before leaving the white
house
maybe he wanted you know to sabotage
trump he took several facilities of
diplomatic property from us
dozens of diplomats had to leave in
three days they were expelled from the
country this is when it all started
you know
we talked about something with blinking
in geneva we now have a new channel
when we
closed this uh conversation on european
security we
we made a proposal once again we offered
you know to roll it all back
to where we we we we
started
so
we we decided
to think about rolling it all back to
before
nobel prize obama took these decisions
nobel prize winner president obama took
these decisions but right now we know
there's this
bargaining
like our ambassador
absolutely needs 12 people who
service him and they have to be taken
out of the quota that we have agreed
upon on the reciprocal basis we're
trying to explain that their quarter has
already been agreed 450 people and on
our side
it's a gesture of goodwill
an enormous gesture because these
include not just the diplomatic missions
and the consulates
but you know it also these 455 people it
also includes the staff of our
diplomatic representation our diplomatic
mission at the united nations
nations even though it has nothing to do
with our bilateral ties it was a gesture
of good will on our part but we
warned them that if this root behavior
continues
and you know
what is it if not rudeness if they say
that if you do not accept these 12
people for our ambassador we're going to
expel ambassador antonoff
well you know if they stick to this
line of behavior then we will have to to
take measures in response as well
mr benedictive
good morning minister colleagues
minister you know very well
that my questions are based on the
questions coming from our
listeners and
i would like to remind everyone that we
have in our studio minister lavrov
a foreign foreign minister
michael mcfaul from california from the
stanford university sent a question to
us
why
didn't russia even try to
get
consent from the
u.n security council
for potential use of force in ukraine if
such use of force
would
be
required why didn't it even try to do
that and why didn't russia recognize the
self-proclaimed republics of donetsk and
luhansk well to be honest
these
questions
are
not
correct
foundationally the first question if i
got that right why didn't russia address
the u.n security council requesting the
consent to use
force if it would be required well i
won't even explain why
it has you know no sense whatsoever
because in practical
diplomatic measures the word if doesn't
exist
and i think the second question was
about the recognition
right alexis yes and it was from me i
think michael mcfall
made a great contribution to uh
undermining everything constructive
about russian u.s relation maybe he just
didn't have a chance to familiarize
himself with the minsk agreements that
were agreed in february 2015 these minsk
agreements say that there is a need to
preserve the unity and territorial
integrity of ukraine
these agreements were adopted
even though several months before
the
luhansk and donetsk republics had
proclaimed their independence and
germany and france
that
participated in drafting the minsk
agreements together with ukraine and
with us
and petro poroshenko you know he joined
this request
and they wanted us to convince the
leaders of the two republics invited to
minsk
they asked to persuade them to put their
signature to the minsk agreements which
essentially changed the
outcome of the referenda that had taken
place before
in
2014. so i think michael mcfuel has to
familiarize himself with the modern
history of this region because the issue
of recognition
has to be viewed in the context of the
firm line we pursue namely to make keef
and to make the west stick to the minsk
arrangements then everything is going to
be fine just as
you know
stipulated by this document which
incidentally has been endorsed by the
u.n security council kamsa musketeer
forever please good morning minister
lavrov
i believe
many people who have read our draft 3gs
we propose to the u.s were surprised
many people were under the impression
myself included
that russia had won some kind of war
whereas the u.s had
lost you know
the radical nature of these proposals
like rolling back to
1997. so what was it
it's obvious that the americans
are not going to roll back without a
serious
reason they're not going
to leave the countries they feel
very comfortable in
right now
so what
what the principles that you
used to draft these treaties
and you know the the documents say that
you
expect an answer very soon
and incidentally this is the fourth
american team you have to work with on
the other side
so
how different are all these american
teams all these american administrations
how important has the role of
personality in history
whom do you think it was comfortable to
work with or not so much
on december the 15th we handed over our
proposals to nato as well as to the us
these proposals
might seem something
exceptional
only if the experts who
assess these proposals assume that the
americans have already taken everything
around
you
so
why bother just you know
put up with it
confine yourself to bare minimum
but what we want as for them to work
with us
with honesty i've just cited the
commitments adopted at the highest level
at the osce they were signed by the
presidents including the president of
the us and these provisions stipulate
that no one is going to strengthen their
insecurity at the expense of others
whereas for americans the freedom of
choice of alliances is sacred sanct but
we say only under con the condition that
it's not gonna strengthen your security
at the expense of others and this is
something you my dear
u.s colleagues have put your signature
to
and this is something we're reminding
them of and we will make sure that they
are not trying to wiggle their way out
of it and provide an explanation how
exactly they interpret these commitments
their president
has assumed when he put
a signature to these documents
and if russia cannot
achieve that if they cannot
you know
fulfill their obligations of these
documents then
it's going to be a very important
revelation
you know
they gave us assurances that nato would
not expand and afterwards they said this
is not what we meant we didn't want to
mislead you we were just
in haste
or let's take the current state of
affairs where
in our own territory
michael mcfaul has just
remembered the u.n security council and
the americans required that the
u.n security council should consider
what we're doing in ukraine why
we are
not de-escalating and this is something
coming from the u.s that has spread its
bases across the world we do not
understand what they're doing in iraq
now and inviting them there so you know
if the americans want to consider the
issue of a force posture
then there is much to discuss
we are not stationed anywhere without
the host nation
consent
and and full compliance with
international law we
observe the commitments we undertake
with
the host nation
americans are trying to create a
hysteria around
the escalation or de-escalation burrell
and blinken it's a kind of a mantra
and they say we hope that russia is
going to choose
the path of diplomacy and i can tell you
that this is something we've always
stuck to since the soviet times
on the outcomes of this diplomacy
include the istanbul
and astana
declarations
stipulating that no one is going to
strengthen their security at the
expense of others this is the embodiment
of diplomacy these documents you know
this is the
example of
compromise they need to do what they
agreed to do and there was a question
about different teams well honestly
vadim i don't want to give any personal
assessment there are other
things we can discuss
but
i'd hate to
express my personal opinion about my
counterparts we have to work with
everyone and with anyone
and i have can tell you that i had
normal relations with all of my
colleagues we always
could
have an honest conversation with any of
them even on
questions there was a great daylight
between us even at the political level
so the round is complete lax
uh once again get to
sputnik you're a diplomat minister
lavrov you're not ever going to
formulate that in
this manner but i'm a journalist well
yes i i
did formulate some interesting things
not as a diplomat but that was not you
know publicly
it was just an accident when the
journalist caught you at that
well we've just saved kazakhstan maybe
we will have to save the day between
tajikistan and kyrgyzstan we saved peace
and karabakh and armenia were always
trying to save our exes as it were so
what do we have as a result
we
have our colleagues from kamsa mosque
pravda who
made a great research a great
investigation
about the russian empire
and uh this is an investigation about
what's written
in textbooks about russia the russian
empire the ussr and the textbooks in
these uh ex-soviet countries and if you
don't know about that you know
you'd be surprised to kind of report
says to our president that russian
language is thriving and kazakh schools
but according to our information it's
not precisely the case i'm not talking
about kazakhstan in particular i'm
talking about
different ex-soviet republics on many
occasions we heard that the
foreign minister is against a simplified
procedure for getting russian
citizenship abroad i know this is not
the case because you made an active
contribution to simplifying the
citizenship grand
granting
so
when our attitude gonna
change when are we going to get our
population back in accordance with the
ethnic principle
and when are we going to
save and protect those citizens who
found themselves abroad even though they
didn't want the country to collapse
there are many
layers to this question i use nicotine
and there are some issues with the
allies and cis and the cst of course
there are problems and no one tries to
hide them
and
those problems are
linked to the fact that new independent
countries that used to
form part of the soviet union and they
also made part of the russian empire
before the soviet union for the first
time
in history they
had a chance to create their own
countries
and their own national states national i
would emphasize it
and
of course they try to
assert their national identity as soon
as possible which is
being accompanied with some accidents
no one would deny it these always
happens when
grant when big empires collapsed well
the soviet union was the heritage of the
russian empire
uh
although i may say it was
more soft than the
russian empire and other empires like
british empire french empire and some
other examples
well this
historical period
present
period
of course we inevitably see some
accidents that i've already mentioned
and of course we want to avoid them
and we will spare no effort in order to
do this including the use of our soft
power
and we have to allocate
much more resources on the soft power
than we do now in our foreign ministry
is actively working on this in order to
develop such decisions from our
governments in order to
make our efforts more systemic
just like
western countries do this
we are still far from
this level
level of those western countries in this
area
and of course
apart from the soft power apart from the
diplomacy and diplomatic means
and
the discussion of these issues during
the context with our partners
of course there is also a reciprocity
that is based on the necessity to take
into
account what we think
about some issues
while
addressing the issues that are of
interest for our partners i mean labor
migrants i mean economic country
economic cooperation
and assistance and many other topics
because our economies are intertwined
econo
european economic union is creating a
lying share
of
economic
wealth and benefits and of course i i
don't see any contradiction here
to the development of friendly and close
relations with the elites of our
neighbors
i'd like to
emphasize
that this situation was caused by the
geopolitical disaster the collapse of
the soviet union
as mr putin said when
25 million people just found themselves
outside of their own countries no one
knew how to
develop the communication between those
new independent countries and states
this
required
a lot of efforts and the fact that now
the situation has normalized
and we see and we understand who is
responsible for what this is quite an
achievement already but the issues that
you
brought up
the issues of
our compatriots should be of course
addressed on the mutual basis and in
this regard i would like also to mention
that
we have to
be more proactive and we have to be more
open in the framework of the cis and we
have to discuss the issues of human
rights
with regards to rights of
persons
who
are from
i would say the group of russians in
kazakhstan and kazakhstan russia
uh millions in azerbaijan and vice versa
although they are not so many of them in
those countries and now we have the
consent of our partners from the cis for
for the following when the cis was
established
there is a stipulation that there will
be a commission on the human rights
in the cis and over a long time there
was no time for this
uh in the past they thought well we
don't have to do this because it's just
for the west to see that we are dealing
with these issues but over the last
years we in the russian federation
we
we proposed
to
discuss this issue on the elaboration
and
development of such a commission that we
that this commission would
uh discuss the issues of human rights on
this
in the cias countries
so
that
we
would be able to
address
those matters and those topics we and
not the western countries western
structures
like european court and human rights
that has long ago
lost
lost its ability to
take into account the principles of
justice and their decisions and rulings
are more and more politicized over the
time
yet another topic that
new marguerita mentioned and those are
compatriots that won't want to go back
to their own country
i personally think
that it would be
in other interests of course someone
should go back and
because they have their family their
uh
relatives in there in in our country but
it will be in interest of our country
and of all our cis partners that all the
citizens of new independent countries
would stay where they were born and
where they live
where they work where they have their
families etc of course this requires the
elimination of all the forms of
discrimination
i would prefer that russians would leave
calmly
and flourishing kazakhstan and other
republics of the
ex-soviet union
and those who want to
move to russia of course they should be
granted this
uh possibility by all means
now many
are
going there because they want to
improve
their conditions and of course
here is
where we have to
work with other agencies other
ministries and russian foreign ministry
is calling for maximum liberalization we
already said this over the last years
with our participation with the
participation of ministry of internal
affairs and other ministers and agencies
we
were able to
propose some amendments to the national
legislation
and those amendments
just tried to
eliminate some
barriers bureaucratic barriers for
those who seek for the russian
citizenship
some barriers that were present at the
moment of filing their petition
among them is the necessity to prove
this source of their income
and at the same time for
those
uh
who
uh for the for the children for the
parents of the russian citizens we
cancelled the
uh
requirement to have the
temporal permit for the residents and
now they can directly file the petition
for the citizenship and just a couple of
weeks ago
well
one month ago on 29th of december our
president
has proposed a
new version
of federal law
citizenship we have worked
on the document with our partners with
other agencies and ministries that are
dealing with this issue
these
draft
legislation broadens
the foundations for given the
citizenship
and this is true for
those who were born
and the territory of russia
and also for their relatives and this
also
true for the simplification
of the issue of giving citizenship for
foreign nationals
and stateless persons
who speak russia russian language
and who are able to integrate
successfully into the russian society of
course this is not an objective
parameter but this is very important
and
of course this
includes the gradients of our
universities from foreign nationals or
stateless persons who graduated from
russian
universities and the participants of
state program
of voluntary relegation
of compatriots and despite the
challenges of the pandemic of last year
there were many new applicants to this
program and the number of regional
programs has exceeded 80
along with the federal program
and we see this program being developed
in the regions of the far east and some
other regions which are the priority for
those who want to relocate to the
russian federations those are the
main programs and the benefits that we
have in force and we would like to do
more because not only
uh the fact that you have your family
uh
and your relative relatives in the
russian federation should be important
for
obtaining
uh
the grounds for
obtaining the russian citizenship i also
think that then there is a number of
uh
issues that should be dealt with and
this work has not been finished
yet
and now we're just trying to capitalize
on what we agreed upon at this stage
the president
has approved our consensus and will keep
working
in order
to
improve conditions for obtaining this
citizenship and at the initiative of the
russian president president putin of
russia
a commission has been established
in the framework of the
united russia political party in order
to
provide our competitors with all the
types of assistance
and
we of course also include those who want
to relocate to the russian federation
and we will provide our competitors all
the necessary assistance in the
framework of your first question so that
they would be able to feel themselves
comfortable in
in the countries where they reside now
governed moscow please you have the flow
oh i beg your pardon roman
and you also mentioned
the article in komsomolska pravda
about the
manuals and history history books that
are being published in
uh sas countries
i will not comment on what estonians
ukrainians lithuanians latvians
about what they write in those books but
as for the cis countries we
over the last years we said that there
is no need
to
give nationalists the pretext
by
uh going into some
uh
complex issues of our common history
that helped all the
peoples that were
living in standards still living in this
common space it helped them to establish
their own statehood and they create the
foundations for their statehood
and
while we do understand the
quest for asserting their own statehood
of course we do think that it is
imperative to avoid those excessive
evaluations
[Music]
that are
favorable for radicals and nationalists
those evaluations should
should be avoided
last year
we
approved the decision to establish a
commission or an association
of scientists
one of the main directions of
its work will be the discussion of the
issues of our common history
in order to well i don't think that they
will prepare some
unified history manuals or history
textbooks textbooks
but they will be able to develop our
common strategies and concepts
that would take into account the
diversity of points of view towards our
common history and this is an important
area of our cooperation
we do have joined commissions of
historians with poland with germany with
lithuania
and in a number of occasions they are
issuing the
common documents and declarations i do
hope that this mechanism will be
constructive and useful
take taking into account
that we work together in many
organizations in cis and sco
uh
and other other organizations roman you
have the floor please mr lavrov i would
like to go back to our relationship
with
the united states well you just
mentioned that
we will keep working with them
you will meet mr blinken in
several weeks but already now after we
receive their response many experts will
almost all of them
say that the united states and nato
would
they are unlikely to change their
position in their stand
and they
say the same that
the ball is at our court i just would
like to understand you say and mr putin
says
that we
would
adopt some countermeasures you say that
those
countermeasures are will be developed by
ministry of foreign affairs among
among other stakeholders
who teaches hinton what direction would
foreign ministry work
in order to return
the ball back to them
by this you mean like cuba venezuela or
some other latin american countries or
maybe serbia or some other
regions like iran can you just give us a
hint
how should we respond
so that these guys
would
use their brain and use the head in
order to give us the response on the
main issues
and main questions that we posed well if
they insist that they would not change
their
position
we
would not do it either because their
position is based on
distortion
of the facts and our position is being
based on what everything put their
signature on
everyone put their signature on i would
i do not see grounds for
reaching the compromise here
because if they are
distorting our previous
decisions that were commonly adopted
that would be the key
test for
for all of us
as for
um for the balls well we play different
games apparently they have
we're they're playing
baseball and we're playing laptop and
some
other games
we just do not have to
they just don't have to
get rid of their responsibility and
that's precisely what they're trying to
do now i mean they're
our nato partners they have to take up
the
answer and the question why don't they
[Music]
do what they agreed upon and we agreed
upon not to strengthen their security at
the expense of others
our ties with the countries of the latin
america and
some balkan countries like serbia with
iran with china and other countries
that
are
decent
on the international
arena they they are not trying to impose
anything on anyone they are always
trying to reach
mutually accepted agree agreements and
the courts
they
are
very rich those religions are very rich
they include humanitarian educational
contacts context and support they also
include our cooperation in military and
military and technical corporate areas
and i would like to assure you that
no matter what would happen in
the area of european security we will
continue developing a relationship
with those countries
the response that we
received we are now
studying it
we already expressed our
valuations we
of course are trying we want to ask a
question why do the western countries do
not
implementing the
the decisions that were adopted
previously if they
were frightened by the fact that we
proposed these documents publicly and if
it would help them to change their
negative attitude towards our
our proposals on imf treaties and other
issues like military drills well that
would mean that the western countries
only understand this type of
conversation like we've done
this i mean publicly
i would repeat that now we would
concentrate and focus on
getting explanations
about the indivisibility of security
because the western countries is trying
to waver off
so right up there
obligations
like the
non-expansion of
nato now
well those were
oral obligations and now we
have a written demands just please give
us explanations on how do you
how do you
how do you do with your written
obligations
please
mr lavrov
speaking about colleagues when
there is a necessity to defend russian
journalists
uh they're
facing some limitations in the united
states in germany we know
that
that you are working with rt the foreign
ministry publicly and not publicly at
the level of
ambassador at the level of deputy
minister
foreign trying to defend and protect
journalists
when we speak about the countries where
the relations are more close
your behavior is rather
is more
it's not that not that fierce maybe
there are there were some examples in
some countries where the head of the
bureau is being jailed and we see the
murders of journalists
like in ukraine and back at that time
foreign ministry uh try to defend our
journeys but when our journalists were
killed in the central african republic
the foreign ministry
hasn't said anything that's the question
of dmitry murataf
nobel prize
winner and the editor-in-chief of nova
gazetta without
investigative procedure new ambassador
of central african republic the
ambassador of the russian federation in
this country has labeled them 3r
the foreign ministry knows this uh and
their relatives and their families do
not know this
there are no
proceedings and procedures
uh there is no declarations from from
the foreign ministry about the
central african republic and the
officials should we do the same about
the about other countries like belarus
and
central african republic well you say
the right things that we have to
always
defend the rights of our citizens not on
the journalists but journalists but also
the rights of all the citizens
um
if we look at the example of what
happens in the united states they are
many journalists are being kidnapped and
we have to defend our
journalists when we do have
uh grounds for this
we expressed our concern
by what is going on with the office of
constables
we talked and discussed this with
vladimir
as i understand
he's the the citizen of
the citizen of belarus and
this changes
everything because there are some
countries that admit double citizenship
and if something
happens on their territory they do use
their own
own legislation well vladimir knows this
i will not go into details there are
some issues that
needs to be addressed in
in silence not publicly we
did
our best so that the belarus authorities
and officials would
would understand it and their position
is they
they are ready to open any bureau any
office
but only with the citizens of the
russian federation
i just would like to repeat that we can
see at this issue on the situation of
the russian journalists in the western
countries
i do think
that
the request so that the only citizens of
the russian federation would work in
that office is not something
exceptional and extraordinary
although i would like to mention that of
course we would like
that all the countries would protect and
defend the rights of
journalists with no exceptions
and in the cases when these rights are
being violated we will keep
we will keep talking about this and
discussing about this
and the
question about the central african
republic and the assassination of three
russian journalists well we will be
ready to
transmit all the information that will
be available to the families of
assassinated russian journalists as for
the who has done this
you know that the investigation is
being done by the
authorities of the central african
republic
i just
i don't want to justify those who who
did it i just want to remind all the
journalists that they should take into
account all the precautionary measures
if they go into some country when there
is internal military
conflict and when there's a terrorist
threat
well they
in all those cases it would be better
for them to notify the foreign ministry
because in the case of some tragedy the
chances to
resolve those problems will be much
higher and in this case they when
they're just like tourists they did not
announce the purpose of their visit well
this is not a just justification but
these
uh
make it even more complicated to
deal with the
security challenges of course we would
like journalists to work everywhere and
for those journalists that are working
in the hot spots i
say i can say that i just admire those
journalists who work there
and our colleagues in in eastern
eastern part of ukraine let's
again and again through you i would like
to
ask those who can influence on the
western
mass media y and that
side of the line of contact in donbas
which is controlled by kiev
journalists are appearing once in
half a year
and they produce
some distorted
reports and investigations and on the
other side of the line of contact our
journalists are showing the results of
these atrocities of
ukrainian armed forces that are bombing
kindergartens hospitals killing people
why don't western journalists show how
the
houses are looking like in the
at this line of line of contact
on the line of contract that have been
controlled by donetsk and luhansk
people's republic republics
as for the situation with the
journalists in central african republic
we are working with this country when
we got the information on the group 3r
we already transmitted this information
to the authorities and we will do
all that we can and we'll spend all of
it in order to
finish this investigation once again we
just want the truth
and i would like to
call on our colleagues and journalists
when they
visit the hotspots if you do not
have if you don't trust us the foreign
ministry i cannot compel you but for the
sake of your own security please notify
us when you go
to some hot spots this would
really help
come somewhere escape router please you
have the floor mr lavrov thank you so
much for
your support um
there is a story of unanimous i think i
would like to thank alexa being addicted
for bringing up that issue
but it's not only about journalists and
mojica has been injured already for four
months
and
there has been even an interrogation
with him i uh requested mr lukashenko
president of belarus
to deal with that problem but there has
been no reaction and as you
as you said that is not only about
journalists as of today
457 russian citizens are
being jailed in belarus those are this
is this that's the data of russian
embassy in minsk
yesterday this list
uh has grown up even more by victoria
sitkiewicz citizen of russia of the
russian federation she was detained she
has been detained she was detained
yesterday
because during the demonstrations
she made a photo i can show this photo
to you this show this selfie was undone
uh in a beautiful red dress
along with the petrol forces that's what
that was was the reason why she was
jailed and
some say that she will be in jail for
two years
what can we do about this
that's belarus maybe our interaction
with them should be a bit different
because that's the part of our state of
union union state and
apparently belarus is the most difficult
the most difficult countries for our
journalists to work in not in germany
not in georgia or in the united states
we keep talking about our common
union state with belarus that we need to
synchronize the legislation what do we
have in the future in this do we have
some
some chances to become a real
union state
well as for the union state as you're
aware
last wouldn't
28 union programs were adopted but they
were not published interestingly
well these are framework documents what
i didn't know they had not been rendered
public i don't think there are any
secrets inside but these framework
documents
mean that we are going to create content
to feel each and every avenue of
cooperation with concrete directly
applicable economic
financial communications decisions and
so on and so forth this as an important
step towards
consolidating the material the
economic
basis and within the next two to three
years this work needs to be completed as
the presidents have decided and this
will mean that we are going to move
faster towards creating a union state
is going to be faster than in the past
and another important thing
several days ago we
were sending boris grisloft to belarus
the new ambassadors there
and you know
the president signed his credentials
and mr simashko belarus
says
ambassador to russia was present and i
reminded
him of an another important avenue
namely making sure that
our rights the rights of our citizens
are equal
a lot has been done but there are still
several
things
to address namely the conditions for
granting access to
medical services to
hotels i mean
that applies to travelers and that's
very important for everyday life but you
started with another question
which is not
linked
to how the union state is going to look
like in the end
the thing is
even if our
penal codes
are
harmonized are absolutely uniform
still there are going to be instances
when russians are detained in belarus
and vice versa
our embassy
is
regularly following
the citizens of russia that have been
detained
our law enforcement agencies are engaged
in contacts and our prosecutor general's
office as well i have not heard of
victoriavic
as
the newspaper of today no
last
year's newspaper why did you say that uh
you
that
she was added to this list yesterday
well it's because she was
detained yesterday as she
a journalist from kamsa mosque probably
know she is just
a russian citizen there are almost 500
russian who is detained in belarus
and of course we're going to
look after her
indeed there are issues that require
very close contacts between our law
enforcement agencies something i would
not like to divulge at this particular
point in time
but we need to make sure that we address
these issues
as allies
as brothers such as we were
it's been one hour
that
we are held in this interview given by
foreign minister lavrov and this is the
third round we
begin margarita
i guess this is going to be my last
question but even if it it's not then
it's not a question i'd like to ask but
a request i'd like to make
i would like to make a request as you
might guess about the future of our
german tv channel never before
never
and uh not in a single place have we
ever encountered anything similar you
know not even in the united states
and this is not just pressure it's
an outright ban on our work in germany
which
is uh introduced at the
under the pretext that
it's not the german authorities that are
doing that
youtube has shut us down in german you
know
artie is still functioning in
english
and we have the biggest audience and not
a single
uh entity tried to shut us down but the
germans
did that they shut us down
you know
we got a license afterwards in serbia
but pressure was exerted and we cannot
even use this license
you know hundreds of people
were involved in building this tv
channel
and trying to win over the audience the
viewers
but
you know
it's all been wasted right now and we
were the only ones to show our content
to the germans
but
i guess we can do something you know
there are reciprocal measures that can
be introduced like
we did with the
uk
and
you know
we
understand that the foreign agents
status is nothing like it is in the u.s
there is no criminal liability for that
but we can use this instrument with
regard to the german media you know some
reciprocal measures well you don't need
to
persuade me but it's been several months
well just
yesterday
our embassy
requested
an explanation the procedures are
ongoing
and it's not the federal agency that is
responsible for that as far as i
understand but the berlin brandenburg
the regional regulator as it were
our lawyers
working at the embassy have had a look
at the presidents
and it seems that axel springer concern
run into similar difficulties but in
their particular case they got a license
very fast
what's difficult about this is that the
germans
are trying to cite their internal
procedures and they're trying to give
them
primacy
over
their obligation obligations under the
european convention on transporter
television broadcasting
they're trying to
find some grounds for the primacy of
their national law
this won't do
because this is going to be like it was
with nato's enlargement this i like and
this i don't like and even though i gave
a promise i'm not going to do that
so
regarding reciprocal measures
i think germans know that reciprocal
measures are going to be invoked if need
be
and when anna lena was here on a visit i
touched upon this issue and i guess the
delegation heard me
and once this conversation is over i'm
going to
have a telephone conversation with anna
leno once again and i'm going to i'm
going to remind her of that
i intended to do that roman guillermo
please yes minister lavrov
the us is witnessing a new scandal cnn
has
published
you know
a report journalists
are citing an alleged telephone
conversation between biden and zelensky
allegedly biding was shouting at
zelensky trying to convince him that
unless zolensky changes his position on
donbasqueef is gonna be
anti-siege and then it's going to be
taken and plundered and pillaged and
after this scandal broke out the
report was taken down from the cnn
website
but what i would like to ask you is the
following just supposing
all of a sudden
they say the ukrainians yes we will
make some amendments to the constitution
we will provide some special stages to
donbass is it going to have some impact
on our
ukrainian policy
because uh
you know
we cannot trust them and there are
several hundreds of thousands of russian
citizens over there and in future this
number can
even be bigger and we understand
the third to these people if they've got
a russian passport
so
are we contemplating such a scenario
and how are we building our policies
structuring our policy with regard to
these
republics
our position has always been the same
namely there is a need
to
implement the means agreements
and good faith following the sequence
enshrined
in the documents
on many
occasions publicly and my colleagues too
have said
that that is the case and during the
meeting between president biden prison
putin in geneva last year president
biden said that he wanted to provide
personal assistance to the
implementation of the minsk agreements
and he said that he understood that
an autonomous status had to be provided
to donbass autonomous was mentioned
so this reflects the minsk agreements
this special status is embodied in this
document and it's understandable what
needs to be done
and i want to believe that because
anthony blinken has assured me as well
that they want to help
the implementation of the minsk
agreements and his deputy too
and they said that they're not gonna
join the nominee foremost but they want
to provide their assistance i think no
one but the us can make kiev stick to
their obligations and if it happens then
we're going to be satisfied with this
outcome
but so far
we can hardly believe that you know
there's a big game going on there you
know
new batches of weaponry have been handed
over to ukraine
and
you know
some would like to view
these transfers of weapons as
kind of
trying to
provoke
people who
would plunge deep into this chaos
because there are some people who want
to benefit from such a conflict
why am i saying that
just the us can
help convince keith
implement the minsk agreements
i will explain uh there's just been a
meeting at the normandy forum at france
germany
um ukraine and russia dmitry kozak went
to paris they once again had a look at
the minsky agreements of the current
state of affairs
but
france germany the eu say that russia is
a party to the conflict so
what kind of agreement can we arrive at
they tell us that we need to
implement the minsk agreements but on
many occasions we we were trying to to
find out kozak and president have been
asking the same question what
does russia need to implement out of the
minsk agreements but what they mean is
that it's all up to us and uh you know
just if we want then everything is just
gonna work out
but
it's not true
and we understand that it means that
paris and berlin are not
going to try to make kiev
implement the minsk agreements whereas
the kiev authorities proclaim loud and
clear that the minsk agreements are just
a pretext
for the preservation of sanctions
against russia
and right now
the
key regime is being used to fuel
tensions
and uh
you know
washington is using this situation to do
that as well and they're not concerned
about the future of ukraine what they
need to do is to fuel tensions around
russia you know just to
shut this dossier down and
you know
just
concentrate their attention on china but
even political scientists american
political scientists understand that
this is not going to lead anywhere
the u.s has been cynically using
russia
and ukraine and even the kiev
authorities have become concerned they
said
why are you evacuating diplomats why so
much
tension we need to have a discussion
so who is
evacuating the diplomats the us the uk
and the canadians the anglo-saxons
though they know something that the
others don't
so
i will
should
probably think about taking
precautionary measures
with regard to our diplomats well we'll
have a look at that
but honestly
i
already answered your question about the
possibility of
recognizing the donetsk and luhansk
people's republic
republics but my answer is very simple
we need to make sure that the minsk
agreements are implemented
because there are many people who are
waiting for any excuse
to
absorb
kiev of uh
sabotaging the means agreements the
document that has been endorsed by the
u.n security council alex a benedictive
thank you
the four radio stations
are now having an interview of foreign
minister lavrov
well you said that
nato's secretary general
uh cyan stoltenberg has lost touch with
reality maybe you live in different
realities incidentally
mr stoltenberg is going to give us an
interview
at 5 00 p.m
well bless him uh do you want to ask him
a question minister lavrov i can pass
your greetings to him or ask
your question you know yeah a listener
from moscow a radio listener sergey
lavrov asks you a question i can easily
do that but
on a serious note i looked at the
sanctions adopted last year
some of them were adopted by the
congress and some by the
finance department most of them were due
to alexey navalny and ukraine
the opc
w carried out an expertise
and established you know there were
three independent laboratories from
sweden from germany
from france
well and they said that there were some
uh traces of uh
a poisonous substance and it seems
absolutely obvious that navalny was
poisoned
and russia requested some information
from germany but russia didn't bring
criminal proceedings
and germany refused any assistance
so wha what do you think uh there is a
report by the opcw and as you are a
member of the opcw you must have seen
this report
okay
do you continue cooperation with the
opcw because we we find ourselves in a
manual here
the european court of human rights are
rusev phobes
the
opcw
the parliamentary assembly the council
of europe
all of them are rusev hopes
mr benedictive
what's that on your t-shirt i thought it
was opcw now it's ho ho ho
yesterday i watched hearing news
i'm sorry i'm going to start from afar
i watched
hearing years
south
north georgia
south essentia
very close to the border
a small village on the territory that
georgia considers to be its own
and the reporter says that i am in the
village of duwani at the line of contact
to my back is the administrative border
that is constantly reinforced by russia
and this house belongs to a georgian
citizen it was burned down
during the war
and the new house is monitored by the
russian military and
a local says that
locals are being abducted
and a reporter
talks about his work over the recent
years at this conflict zone
and
the news anchor says it's been 14 years
since the war people live in difficult
conditions almost on a daily basis they
are abducted they lose their property
their land russian soldiers detain them
and then
you know it's gaga the
journalist and then the anchor says
after the ussr collapse georgia was the
first republic that ran into a surge of
separatism and military conflict and
thousands of refugees cannot get back to
their homes
but it doesn't specify what kind of
separatism it was you know because there
was some
separatism before the collapse of the
soviet union when gamsahurdia
was uh
you know demanding that everyone
had to
georgify as it were and he didn't
consider situations to be georgian
citizens he wanted them to leave
and then you know a stroke of genius
in conclusion
in 2008 the anchor says
when the conflict
entered the
military phase russia
joined south asia
and helped it
your news
positions itself as the embodiment of
diversity and
uh uranus doesn't even mention this
threat recite conflict and how it all
started but why am i asking this why am
i telling you that you asked me the
question about the opcw
without mentioning the most important
things that need to be mentioned in
order for us to understand what's
happening and
you know
it might create an impression
for michael mcfaul or other
listeners who are not reversed in the
subject that
it's all
true
what you said
but in reality it's different
germany has obligations under the
convention on
mutual assistance and criminal affairs
and
these obligations
do not need to be accompanied by
criminal proceedings
we can only bring criminal proceedings
if we have the facts
and
this doesn't prevent us from invoking
this procedure of mutual assistance with
many other
countries
we
have loads of materials
we are sending across the world
which need to be accessible to the media
to
echo of moscow in particular
we have not
got a response who flew over to russia
to get alex a navalny
and this aircraft
was uh requested one day before
alexey navalny felt ill
we do not understand why it was the case
why it was
rented in advance
we asked some
other questions about the facts
the pilot didn't want perchick to take a
bottle why did he give his consent to
that in the end
there was a sixth passenger and there
are many other questions and all of them
were addressed to bundestag to the
german parliament why cannot we
interrogate pefce
the germans say that she didn't
communicate with navalny that she didn't
visit him in the clinic whereas pepcik
says that she did
she is not sharing this bottle to anyone
bottle that she brought over when we
asked for this bottle to be given to us
to
investigate it to analyze it our
requests
well they denied
and
the conclusions
about traces of poisonous substances and
navalny's body were made
after his treatment in charity
and charity when he was in charity they
didn't find anything but when he was
transferred to the bundeswehr clinic
they found in three days these traces
and you know when the same had happened
to
skripal and when we had said that
highly likely wouldn't do that we needed
facts
you know there are 150 patents in the us
on novichok and
it was developed in europe too and back
then france and germany and sweden
were assuring us that they didn't have
technologies for that and if you don't
have technologies
three days is not going to be enough for
you to find traces of these poisonous
substances in anyone's body
everyone knows that first germans were
telling us that this was secret military
information and that why that is why
they were not going to share with us so
they were
accusing us of
attempted homicide and we
and you
refuse to provide us with any
corroboration
then they said we would have provided
you with these materials but navalny
didn't
authorize that
navalny's lawyer is accusing
meek me peskov
because you know paskov has allegedly
accused
navalny of working with the cia and
mitri peskov
said that the cia agents visited navalny
when he was in hospital
so
isn't that enough
and
they the germans refused to give
any
material corroborating what they're
saying to us
then we asked them
and they referred us to the opcw the
opcw referred us to
germany
so it's a vicious circle
and if you read the report itself you
see that it's police u.s that has been
established found out in the body and
it's not novichok
it's just the substances that are
similar to some substances that are
prohibited by the cwc
and the formula is not provided to
anyone it's a secret
neither the germans nor the swedes
but
it all you know boils down
to the formula
so i
think that the west has no real grounds
for these accusations and they are
simply doing that to
fuel tensions
[Music]
i told you that the aircraft was rented
one day before
and on that very day
the germans
referred to the higg
asking for assistance then they said it
was a misprint you know there are many
curious things in this
scenario
and
even when this request came through
this opcw secretariat was trying to hide
it from us for several days
because the germans had asked them not
to tell anyone doesn't it raise some
suspicions it does for me
so i asked the viewers the listeners of
everyone to
well i would like to refer you to the
website of our foreign ministry there is
a list of questions so far left
unanswered by the west
and the last question
vladimir
and then the interview is going to be
over
minister lavrov the most popular
question today
yesterday so is there going to be a war
with ukraine
we started with this question
vladimir nikolaevich but you
started with this question but you spoke
so
eloquently so
it's been one hour and a half many
things might have changed well it's if
it's up to russia there's not gonna be a
war but i do not rule out but there are
some who would like to provoke military
action and the kiev
regime
is not controlling
many
military i think there are 100
000 at the line of contact even
according to the western data
and many of these soldiers are not under
direct control of the cave authorities
a great number of troops there
are former
volunteer battalions
some resistance units
and
they are provided with
man pads
you know this information is out there
in the media they get manpads
and there are urges to them you know to
take the
hunters guns because
the man pads are not going to be enough
for everyone
so it's kind of a militaristic psychosis
and you know after that
shooting case i i cannot rule out such a
provocation
aren't we talking to the lenski
he used to be a member of the kamsa mall
you know in the first channel and he was
a pianist
so why aren't we talking to him
well vladimir putin has already given an
answer to that if president zelinski
wants to talk about normalizing our
bilateral relations
that are suffering because of the damage
done by the unilateral actions by the
kiev regime
which we had to respond to
then if he wants to talk then we are
willing he can come to moscow to sort
you to st petersburg as they agree on
that but if he wants to talk about
donbass
then
he has to
go to the contact group
because
as per the decision of the normandy
format
it's
up to the contact group to
discuss
settlement directly between kiev and
luhansk in donetsk and if he says he
doesn't want to talk to donetsk or
luhansk
well it's not good
it's bad
but it's bad for the internal ukrainian
crisis
as far as relations with russia are
concerned if he has anything to say if
he has any ideas about you know the
steps that
were
so damaging to our relations then we are
willing to discuss that to have a look
at that
you know a new meme from uh minister
lavrov
please refer to the country group
and you know
and another thing i would like to
clarify what about our diplomats are we
gonna evacuate our diplomatic staff from
kiev we were discussing the psychosis
that is fueled in ukraine
it has been instigated by the
uh by great britain by the european by
the united states and by some european
countries in the part of this hysteria
are those declarations that everyone
needs to leave ukraine in the citizens
that are
in ukraine for their own business and
the diplomats they are all being called
to leave this country with the families
etc
and the staff
is being called to
leave ukraine we cannot
uh turn a blind eye to they say well if
they do this
even the ukrainians did not ask them to
do so maybe these countries have some
ideas
on about what would happened what would
happen
well mr lavrov this happened right after
you said something to mr blink in on
your meeting what was it that you told
him or showed him
so that when he
returned
he said that there is a need to evacuate
diplomatic stuff what was that well no
mr benedictive
my
i didn't say anything
to him
when we had a personal meeting after
this he told me well
if something happens
well then there will be
our
stuff so
well that was awkward for me that's what
i told him that's how i i responded so i
can assure you that we discussed the
only thing the security guarantees and
then
i said that
the situation with our diplomatic
missions
is completely unacceptable so in a
couple of weeks we will have
another
meeting between the specialists
so i can assure you that there are no
threats and there were no threats but we
cannot leave everything without an
analysis so we
do
we trying to analyze what is behind the
actions thank you thank you so much dear
colleagues thanks a lot
[Music]
foreign
you